good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy hump day
hope everyone's having a great wednesday
i am
happy hump day you guys i didn't realize
it was humpty until you uttered those
immortal words well that's because i
just haven't you know mounted you yet
yet is the key word um it's wednesday it
is our final show of the week as summer
break continues jackie is very busy
getting her life together so let's
discuss
housekeeping housekeeping first and
foremost so this is our final show of
the week there will be no breaking bread
tonight so we will see you next week to
break some delicious
toasty bread
full of gluten bread honestly we should
start another show that's like us being
really boring and call it gluten-free
breaking gluten-free bread yeah i love
that where we just like do you know the
takes that everyone which is saying we
do the bare minimum no not even that but
like we don't give our like unpopular
opinions you know say what everyone else
is saying very lukewarm
takes yeah i like that i like that too
gluten-free chocolate or maybe we'll do
that on april fool's on breaking bread
yeah okay remember that for april fools
we always like to do a little something
for you guys so this is our final show
in the the studio this week and final
episode again no breaking bread tonight
and then next week we have a podcast
every day but it's just going to be uh
podcast only while jackie gets her
studio set up we want to like start our
new interface premium we got to wait
till it's all set yeah so we will do
that hopefully the week after next yes
exactly so next week is audio only but
we will be here every day
and that's the housekeeping also there's
a new episode on patreon a new vlog of
my farewell evening you get to see
claudia plan this you know extravaganza
for me to say goodbye and it's really
cute everyone people are calling it our
most emotional episode yet and i didn't
feel like it was emotional i didn't even
feel emotional i didn't feel emotional
being there i didn't feel emotional
watching it i don't know if that's like
something's wrong with me no no
it wasn't because i was also like i it
wasn't even like sad but everyone's like
why am i crying i'm like i don't know
why are you crying it wasn't sad we were
like drinking and it was fun sad was the
way that i looked oh exactly
that was sad what was sad was how my
night turned out but oh yeah that's
neither here nor there so there's always
content on the patreon so head over to
patreon.com the morning toast i think
that's the most important housekeeping
announcement is like even though
tomorrow we shan't be here patreon is
there for you you know i don't like to
compare housekeeping announcements
because i have one too that's like so
important maybe maybe like just as
important you know it's interesting no
all housekeeping is important right
exactly so um tickets available at
girlsnojob.com tour the first three
shows for the final end vlog tour are
available new haven new jersey
west hampton
no new haven connecticut red bank new
jersey and west hampton new york
tri-state area i'm coming for you girls
no job.com
tour i do believe two out of three of
the shows are sold out of meet and greet
but i think one of them has eight left
that's what i heard as of yesterday so
don't quote me on that
it's your chance so if you want to meet
and greet your girl which so many people
did yesterday tell us everything about
your day
in boston i want to talk about boston
what's its nickname the uh bean town no
that's not no that's chicago the windy
city nope that's chicago
why does chicago get two no and also
like
no sorry beantown beantown but it's
confusing because the bean is the big
architectural like art thing is in
chicago boston is beantown and that's
where you were and i'm sure ben felt
right at home well jane's bangs i was 30
minutes outside of boston i was in
natick so you were 30 minutes outside
the bean yeah
yeah so i wasn't able to flick the bean
which was sad um i have to talk about
because first of all
it was so crazy
there's just so much to say first of all
i don't know why like so we
sell in total wine sports society is
sold in total wine and so when we wanted
to do a boston meet and greet they
suggested this store i'm not sure why um
but i know why after meeting all the
people first of all a lot of um
companies are headquartered around there
so a lot of corporate girlies came right
after work in their blazers and when i
tell you maybe 50 people who work at tj
maxx corporate headquarters we were
right around the corner we passed it it
said tjx i'm like is that tj maxx it was
like the same font and it just felt like
really kind of meant to be share to be
near so close to the tjmx headquarters
after we raved about them on the toast
and when i tell you like every single
person who works at t.j.maxx
is a toaster um and apparently like the
building was lit ablaze last week when
you were going on and on about your
white sneakers oh wow and are they
constantly lit and ablaze because you're
always proclaiming to be a maxinista
they're like it's it's literally a
partnership waiting to happen like we're
ready for our line at t.j.maxx like
let's just make it happen okay i'm so
ready i'm a jacksonista i'm a maxinista
you're a clacsonista but i actually am a
mac city star you are and a fashionista
don't get it twisted you can be both
that's what people that's the point of
tj maxx that's what people don't
understand you think you have to choose
but you have tone right we're ready tj
we're ready
we're hitting every talking point so it
was our biggest meet and greet yet we
totally sold out of product at the store
which was so crazy and it's just like so
helpful for our business um
it was madness like the store was
closing people it was just like it was
chaos and i got so i got to meet so many
amazing toasters like oh geez who like i
wasn't sure are still toasters you know
people who came to like our meet and
greets like i remembered people and you
saw them again right literally people we
met at our morning breath live show with
teresa giudice like years and you're
just not sure if people like keep up
with the toast so it was old it was a
girl came she was like i literally found
out about the toast three weeks ago on
tick tock like it was just old new
friends well lest we not forget that the
one time some research report ran a
study of the most popular podcasts by
state we were the number one podcast in
massachusetts and new jersey so the
bostines show up and show out i really
need like the data company who put
together that research study to do it
again it was 2018. yeah but what if we i
mean we've only become more popular
but there are so many new shows since
then so what if we don't even have one
state i believe that we do like i really
believe that in my heart what do you
think the state is it's something in the
tri-state area it's like do you think
it's new jersey or massachusetts what do
you think is stronger
i don't know my ticket sales at red bank
are like really fire honestly like i was
really surprised i think it would be new
jersey but i'd love to hear the fanfare
from the boston's okay it was just so
amazing like we were all crying
screaming laughing throwing up
i
literally let a sing-along like because
i was talking to some girls and they
were like we love bryson's rice so i
started singing bryson's tries literally
the line of three hundred people and
brazen's jazz and and then i just
started to lead toast tunes and like it
really kind of cemented we have a video
of it it really kind of cemented how we
need to use because that would just be
like dude and they would just go
like they just they knew exactly and
then what else did we sing we did um
even like the husbands were like oh yeah
like zuma they were like i like the beat
it was so iconic and i got of course
amazing gifts and i did bring a couple
for you i saw the bag because you're
moving and so if i don't give them to
you now like i'll never be able to so
let's just go through some of the gifts
this was a personal favorite we each got
crewnecks that are blue with a little um
sketch on the breast of brass and stress
here is the uh
the bryce one this is gorgeous ready
it's really cute sorry this is gorgeous
um a lot of people just like handed me
bags and i wasn't sure like what was for
me and what was for you i had to assume
um hamnet a novel of the plague was for
you and maybe she thought you would like
this book let's see it it's moving
timeless and ever relevant according to
npr in england 1580 the black death
creeps across the land an ominous threat
infecting the healthy the sick the old
and the young alike okay sounds
traumatizing sounds traumatized in like
giving the last two years 1580 is a
little before my area of peak interest
but i really take book recommendations
seriously and i will give this a shot
okay good this next one is like so crazy
so thoughtful so unique oh my god i'm
really not ever been done so we're
excited it is a painted oh my god hand
beaded we both got one denim jacket it
is totally custom so let me just show
you the front
cute little denim jacket
it's really sweet she thinks i'm so
small it's pearls all over the side
on the arm it's a heart that's painted
and says harry oh my god what does yours
say theo uh-huh
um it's so cute and the girl who gave it
to me works for the company who makes
them so she had that's sick and so
what's the company if anybody um there's
a tag
oh it's one of those fonts that are like
wedding fonts you can't [ __ ] read it
yeah and tia amala so auntie oh wait
auntie a amoroso oh cute and tia
and tia amoroso okay wait i got more
this one is like really you're you're
gonna quake from this one ready
a ray done mug it says happy camper and
there's a little school bus on the back
oh my god the school bus but i got a lot
of ray done mugs when i did um
dallas meet and greet i took them all
home and i did get like multiple happy
campers but you can never have them
it sounds like you're becoming somewhat
of a redone collector like you might
need a china cabinet in your new house
for all of your redone items i would
love that because every time i see them
they make me smile especially since they
were all bought for me from you guys
which is so sweet and they're just so
thoughtful i can't reiterate enough how
like you don't need to bring gifts but
they are so welcome and appreciate it i
just wanted to feel like an obligation
like not a birthday party like it's so
overwhelming like you don't have to
bring your presence is merely a presence
and then somebody brought you press-on
nails and i thought they were for me and
she was like no they're for jackie oh
i'm not sure why well we do love
press-on we do we are press-on-nail
girlies these are pretty yeah they're
stunning and actually i've heard good
things about the drugstore brand kiss
people say it's like better than the
expensive ones cool cool
so those were my um
thank you so much i love a bounty from a
meet and greet i really do and some of
my most prized possessions like in life
are just happen to be from meeting great
so i'm always wearing these random
t-shirts people on my messages the one
that says arkansas i have so many my
arkansas one my georgia georgia georgia
georgia one my whataburger shirt my one
that has um lisa rina's monologue for
mandy cohen's bachelorette bridal baby
shower there's no shirt that you wear
more than arkansas all those ones you're
like i've never seen the lisa arena one
george's sounds familiar
uh what whataburger all last week okay
but that arkansas one everyone knows it
it's the red neckline and the white
t-shirt and the brown um chicken and
broccoli stain it's in your like top
five rotation of pajama shirts up there
with skeletons up there with sexy
shoulder black and sexy shoulder pink
with like the holes love that but you
also wear that on the show sometimes no
i've never i haven't worn that shirt out
of the house in maybe five years okay so
maybe i was in your house and you were
wearing it i wore it when you came to my
house on sunday
that would explain that and then what's
the fifth one
rotation it's it's like a striped shirt
it's like white purple blue which you
know what i mean of course
yeah and most of my favorite rotational
shirts are from meet and greets when
people are like oh my god where'd you
get that arkansas shirt i love arkansas
i'm like i have no idea like i can't
ever do a swipe up or anything because
it's from a meet and greet it's an
amazing shirt it's heavenly actually
nothing i think about i haven't seen it
in a while because it stays at the top
of my laundry spotter borrowed it 100
it stays at the top of my laundry it's
like every time i do laundry it's like
right at the top but now i'm really
thinking i have to work it my closet's
really messy so i need to get my shirts
in order you must get your shirts in
order my rotational shirts all right
well those are the three things i needed
to talk about okay great i feel all
caught up per usual you know we haven't
spent a moment apart i guess you did
leave the state yesterday and so we
talked less than usual yes i was so
booked and busy but i don't have
anything that i need to tell you about
that i didn't tell you about any
anything with royal does he going to
college yet
no he's just missing you i miss a whole
day and it's like he's literally
starting elementary school oh my god
it's so upsetting stop don't even no
all's good and just looking forward to
shooting the [ __ ] with you yeah we have
uh dear toasters it's wednesday so art
by segment if you ever want to write in
dear toasters gmail.com we have some
salacious like real drama real
quandaries i feel like a couple of them
are going to be one of those situations
where we really don't know like what
advice
yeah okay cool well also like the
stories are interesting today like i
wouldn't say there's anything that you
absolutely have to know but i think a
lot of things like you'll be better off
for knowing yeah yeah we'll see then
let's dive right into the five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning toes
today's episode is brought to you very
appropriately by spirit society
delicious the taste of summer keep going
oh my gosh i'm that just made me thirsty
i would love to crack open a nice cold
spritz society get a nice gorgeous glass
perhaps a ray done mug
some ice
pour it over the top i love spritz
society because not only can you drink
from the can like a slob but
if you pour it into a glass and i love
glassware
each flavor has a corresponding color so
it's a gorgeous thing to behold no one's
gonna get confused like oh is that my
sparkling water or my spritz because
it's not clear you know what's so
exciting is like our new tagline that
we're using for obviously the warm
months is the taste of summer and you
literally wrote it that is exciting yeah
and that's how some of the greatest
things happen 100
so our company sprit society is a family
business you know we love family over
here and we are just sick and tired of
drinking we love drinking and we're sick
and tired of drinking disgusting things
we decided to create the beverage that
we wish to see in the world and then a
sports society sparkling cocktails you
can sip on summer all year long with
spritz society sparkling cocktails these
sparkling cocktails aren't like most
because they're made with real
california white wine and natural fruit
flavors speaking of flavors there's one
for everyone from our four ogs which is
grapefruit blood orange pineapple and
lemon to our latest launch peach if you
can't decide on which one you want to
try first and you just love them all try
the ultimate spritz taste test with the
variety pack it's eight cans two of each
original flavor and then you can add
peach to your cart to get the complete
set you can use code toast today and get
ten percent off grapefruit blood orange
pineapple lemon and peach spritz society
cheers sprit society.com code toast you
can always use code toast and there's
never been a better time because we're
heading into the weekend it's wednesday
and it's the summer and it's so [ __ ]
hot outside oh my god it's disgusting
it's offensive it's satanic and it's
demonic yes these temperatures are wild
you would never know it from claudia's
jacket today it's freezing in here but
we try to dress weather agnostic on the
show because these episodes are
evergreen i never know when someone's
going to be watching it no and like
seriously if i was just wearing my
little dress i'd be freezing it's so
cold in here and i'm not complaining
like that sounded like a complaint it
wasn't no no no but it's like yeah you
can't dress for the streets and then sit
here and that's when we wear blankets
i'm a lady in the streets and i've got a
freak on the toast oh that's her damn
shirt her damns no seeing you in the
street you would never know what you put
down here what i do yeah no people think
oh what a nice girl she's walking your
dog ocean maybe she's going to work she
has a personal laptop they don't know
like what i come on here and do like
literally
change lives
but maybe they do maybe they listen
they're like oh there's claudia this is
the biggest podcast in new york [ __ ] oh
my god i wonder what the biggest podcast
in new york is
i feel like
yeah like one of those like boring ones
yeah yeah for sure but i wonder what the
most interesting podcast in new york is
you know
there can only be one but you know how
spotify breaks out podcast charts like
by country they break out like songs by
country too like why not by state and
then every day would change so some days
we would be the biggest podcast
somewhere you know
i feel like once a year we talk about
this research
study that was done literally five years
ago that we never got over i believe a
lot of the new listeners here so maybe
they haven't heard us talk about it um
and i know that there are actually is at
least one toaster who works for the
research company she was like oh man
that's my company that did it so fun
like we're trying to do another one that
was two years ago girl where's the study
i know but claudia be careful what you
wish for what if the study comes out and
we're not on it i would we're bigger
than ever i know and the study came out
in 2018 when we launched our show but
yes we are bigger than ever but like
so is podcasting and there's so many new
shows huge shows celebrities we're
communicating with i totally get what
you're saying like be careful what you
wish for but like i'm [ __ ] curious
like i think i'd rather know and be
disappointed than not know at all you
think because even ignorance is blessed
even if the research study comes out and
we're irrelevant uglies like we still
have like a super successful podcast in
business like they can't take it doesn't
change that right
facts like we're literally it's just
it's just new facts right sets of facts
but our facts still remain true have you
actually checked to see if the study was
done because honestly i haven't like
maybe it maybe it has come out and we
weren't on it and that's why it never
graced our desks most popular podcasts
by state podcast by state but the thing
about podcast uh numbers or charts like
you can't get podcast analytics so a lot
of this stuff is like [ __ ] up that's
the top podcast in every us state from
january 2021 are you ready oh my god we
haven't heard from them
what's a website okay this is from
waycroft the last one from 2018
is from um like a research company
inverse.com i trusted simple texting was
the infographic
and there we are okay that's we're from
the inverse yeah yeah i remember that
one and they're from 2018. of course
we're in like tiny states with like
small is it new jersey is like the
second smallest state and so are you
going to go to 2021 i'm going i'm going
it's just i'm trying to i'm nervous i'm
putting off the inevitably because if we
haven't heard about it since last year
like we're irrelevant yeah someone at
raycroft would have been like girls you
made it or someone like would have
posted it in like a facebook group or
sent it to us here it is here it is
oh my god i'm going to vomit we're not
on it
there's you were right we never should
have looked
but it's hard for me to read like really
quickly come on wyoming
no i wasn't expecting like i'm expecting
tri-state area
new york new jersey massachusetts so you
want to know what the new york the most
popular podcast is anatomy of a murder
that's interesting because i've never
heard of it new jersey is the mismatch
never heard of that either and
massachusetts is dead and gone
wait i'm crushed i'm crushed what are
these shows like no offense i'm in
chicago
illinois is so much bigger than just
chicago that was bill simmons
at least i've heard of him
you know that makes sense like people in
new york tasteless hate them i just like
that this doesn't feel right they must
have been working with like not even
because of us i'm just saying the other
shows on it we're like where's like
caller daddy or joe rogan they're in
some states but
not in as many as you would think so
that's why i just don't think this is
legit i'm crushed you were so right jack
i mean never should have checked
curiosity and what's that one the daily
that's the one that's always your number
one it's not even on here for any oh no
it's on here for d.c
sounds like they literally made that up
it sounds like they just like i had a
feeling yeah i agree i'm not going by
this sorry waycroft fake news and maybe
maybe like maybe we're not on that list
because we're so popular in so many
states like our audience is just like
yeah and we're pretty like state
agnostic like you don't have to be in a
certain state to enjoy this show you can
be in every state you just need to be in
a certain state of mind which is steamy
vibes
100
okay next time i'll just listen to you
like
that's just what we've been doing here
like put a damper in my day shut it down
shut it down
i just don't think it was right
i just never heard of some of those
shows how could be the they're not i
just can't i completely agree but i'm
not saying that's because we're number
one but like if every single one was
like bill simmons the daily joe rogan
call her daddy like i would be like oh
okay yeah we didn't make it and those
three guys from the comedy show bateman
armchair expert yeah um and crime junkie
yeah i would say yeah yeah no for sure
we didn't make it and that we suck
but that is not factual it just hurts
it's not factual
so i only operate in facts right right
right
i think we should move on i think so too
so now we could get into the stories yes
we really could
like i wasn't paying attention i'm so
busy all day like i don't even know what
was going on in the world around me
here's the moral of the story you didn't
miss any one particular thing but there
are some interesting stories as per
usual we will discuss
honey boo boo is undergoing a 13 000
weight loss surgery with her boyfriend
honey boo boo is coming to the big apple
in august after that birthday that'll
catapult us we're booking that'll
catapult us to the number one podcast
where is she from
mcintyre georgia maybe will be the
number one podcast in georgia you know i
get so confused between the town in
which
honey boo boo is from and the town in
which kenneth parcell is from because
it's macon georgia is
kenneth
and i think mcintyre is the boo-boos
interesting i'm sure
interesting anyway she's coming to the
big apple in august after her 17th
birthday to undergo weight loss surgery
her manager confirmed to page six on
wednesday morning the star will receive
a suture sculpt endoscopic sleeve from
weight loss dr stephen bates which can
cost about 13k tmz reporting what's that
doctor's example
sh 13k if you want to start saving yeah
same for me
um alana thompson aka honey boo boo
reportedly weighs 275 pounds and is
looking to drop 150 after various diets
didn't give her the results that she
wanted the stars concerned her weight is
genetic and believes surgery is the only
way to reach her goals
well i'm all for i think her boyfriend
is going under the knife alongside her
he also has weight loss goals in mind
i'm all for people taking charge of
their bodies you know like if that's
what you want to do i would love that
journey for you
um
and i just really like something i
didn't see for the booboo fam when i was
watching them on tlc back in the day
before the show got cancelled because um
mama june was dating a
child molester i think that's why they
got cancelled um i didn't see them
becoming like such tabloid like click
bait like her manager told this
publication what website is this page
six yeah and that uh she's plans to get
weight loss surgery like they're just so
like no and like where did they get her
weight from yeah the manager like
they're fully like tabloid like [ __ ]
you know and i just didn't see that and
like the doctor is in the report too i'm
sure it's like some sort of collab
right right right she's getting a
discounted rate she's not saving she's
not spending 13 grand if he's in the
press release
yeah maybe she's going for like four or
five
yeah
yeah which we love like a discounted you
know frugal queen
yeah but i will say i think 17 is a
little young to be getting surgery of
any kind yes um but i think with
surgeries like these like the reason why
you get approved for like a surgery at
this age is because like you're the
alternative like poses a bigger health
risk you know yeah no and there's a lot
of different surgeries for different
both like cosmetic health etc but i
think it's like a big surgery to get at
17. yeah and you know actually i landed
on the honey boo side of tic toc for a
little while you know they still have a
show it's obviously not as popular and
as big as the tlc one was
but um apparently it's very juicy
i'm sure like i was watching most
celebrities like just get weight loss
surgery and like they're not putting out
a report to pay chicks right so she's
i'm sure she's sharing everything yeah
no but not even about the weight loss
surgery like the family dynamics i think
alana thompson the youngest daughter
lives with pumpkin one of the older
daughters who when i watch the show she
was like so chaotic and like she was
like
it was one of those shows you couldn't
um watch while you were eating because
they were always doing like disgusting
things like putting mayo everywhere like
it would just make you nauseous and
pumpkin was like the ringleader of all
that stuff but the clip that i saw it's
like pumpkin has really grown up settle
down she's like a nice man kids and
alana lives with her because she has
like provided such a stable home
yeah it sounded really nice and i just
haven't like you know kept up with them
in a while and so much has changed and
that's just part of life you know
growing up yeah even honey boo grows up
and that's hard yeah and that's the
moral of the story yeah but i will
always have like an extremely special
place i think a lot of people have a
very warm place in their heart for her
there's a reason why she went from
toddlers and tiaras to having her own
show and she captured the hearts of a
lot of she did they were like they were
just chaotic but in a really um
like earnest earnest yeah all-american
kind of way yeah
so i hope that honey finds what she's
looking for and you know i think mama
june had a similar surgery so um it's
obviously something they've seen success
with and they they like yeah so i think
it's great anyways keep an eye out for
her in the big apple in august and keep
an eye out for her on the toast because
let's just manifest it i'm not really
into manifesting whatsoever i consider
it jinxing but i feel that
that's something that i feel like is a
good manifestation because if it didn't
happen it would be fine but it would be
wonderful if it were to manifest itself
yeah and i'm like a huge like if you
know her manager who's obviously very
busy these days is watching this like
we're huge fans we love alana remember
when alana was on dancing with the stars
junior
no it was an iconic moment in television
history
it sounds like it yeah i can't believe i
missed it you know speaking of iconic
moments in television history you know
what i've been thinking about watching
the season of celebrity big brother uk
that tiffany pollard and gemma were on i
think that you should because
you have been quoting obviously
everything of sort comes from nothing of
the sort and it's always like lived
around free in our minds but you have
been quoting her more than ever i'm sure
it's making him surround on tick tock
and i do feel like you should dive
deeper into that it gives you so much
joy
i'm sure there's more where they came
from pretty much i would let gemma know
i think i should watch it too do it yeah
that's like on my list
and it's taking like with each day i
breathe it's moving higher up on my list
of things to do you know i love that for
you yeah and i also think it just
happened to be like a really good season
i've also never watched celebrity big
brother so i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
get into it get into it i love new
things for you thank you me too are you
ready for our next story yeah that's
loading from people magazine yeah
the tellers are making news of course
they are because kelly sperry made miles
shave his mustache immediately after he
filmed top gun maverick oh that's
shocking which is just so funny because
so many people are now being inspired by
the look and
men across the globe are growing the
mustache while chatting with people uh
miles teller opened up about how his
wife wasn't a big fan of the facial hair
he sported while shooting the beloved
summer blockbuster top gun maverick
mavia he said my wife maybe made me
shave it immediately after filming and
although she wasn't thrilled with her
husband's mustache many moviegoers were
and have been sporting similar facial
hair all while documenting their furry
upper lip looks on tick-tock he reacted
to the trend saying i'm a big fan of it
if it makes them more confident then
more power to them but we'll see maybe
it'll be a good summer trend and then
die out
yeah i'm not a mustache girl that's my
question for you i stand with kelly
completely and always
um and forever
so i support the decision every time ben
has like a beard and he shaves he'll
like come out of the bathroom with just
the mustache on like and
beg me
beg
for me to let him keep it and it'd be
one thing if it was like a full
mustache but it's like really thin and
like straight and i'm like ben you
literally look like a predator like take
it off like people are not gonna let you
into like local restaurants and stuff
and he always so i fully identify with
kelly like and i do believe that a man's
facial hair is in control
it could should and can be controlled by
the woman in the relationship yes so
they're the one who has to look at it
yeah it's just like it's interesting how
like
miles taylor's so handsome that like
even quote unquote like the worst
looking version of himself like that his
wife doesn't like still creates trends
do you know what i mean yes
and and
that's just really funny so relatable
it's funny that it became such a trend
that like so many people are sporting
the mustache the seeing other people
with mustaches doesn't bother me but if
i had a mustache in my own home
you would feel threatened
and unsafe i think i would feel unsafe
yeah
now that i think about it i don't think
i've ever seen zach with facial hair
does he shave every day no he does
scruff he lets it like build up a few
days and then when we like have anything
to do right like a wedding not even we
have don't have a wedding every week but
you know even if we're going to dinner
or something like then he'll shave it
but he does has been letting it build up
interesting but i've never he's never
like come out with even just a message
don't give him any ideas do you remember
ben's like covet beard yeah that was
like a really really hard time for me
i'm sure for a lot of people for every
person who had to like even come within
six feet of him like it was really hard
for us but i don't think he's the only
one who did that you know so everyone
was struggling yeah and now like i'll
get timehop photos or just memories on
my phone from that time and like i
didn't i knew it was bad i'd pull up a
picture yeah i knew it was bad when um
when i was living through it but it's so
much worse than i ever could have
imagined with perspective because also
it grows so
you never see the stark change from
right clean shaven to mustache and when
you and i and our sisters deigned to
have a meal together during covid that
was when ben had um his moustache or his
beard and the photo that like broke the
internet and broke the hearts of
millions of nurses um was of ben with
his crazy-ass beard so that memory just
like triggers me so hard like for the
time my husband like i just triggered me
and the time that you know the world
literally rebelled against us when sorry
we did [ __ ] just want to say it
wasn't millions of nurses it was one
fake nurse yes wait do you remember uh
what time of year yeah may 2020 yeah may
2020 so let me just find the great the
forsaken photos of
that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh wait no
that's shapiro he looks so much like ben
with the beard
i'm like feeling nervous oh i actually
hear wait
i have pictures of him shaving it i was
like so excited so funny if you guys
want to see like i was literally
documenting the moment finally and you
know when ben's he's never for the time
that i've known him growing out of beard
but the longer his hair gets it gets
like a little red i think that's a thing
with men like yeah i think the beard is
always like a little lighter than the
hair and sometimes it's red oh my god
like literally who is that
wow i'll post to this on our instagram
with ben's approval wow and maybe we can
rewrite the narrative of this rooftop
dinner because right it wasn't the
dinner that you know it was the market
you know launched a thousand ships it
was the dinner where ben had a beard
right we need to reset the narrative
because it was such a great evening like
we hadn't seen each other in two months
and we were all outside being very safe
and having a good time with our family
um and i think we should repost the
picture that started it it's just so
crazy in hindsight like knowing now we
what we know about covet like we have
all the information like looking back at
what we got in trouble for and like
is everyone like where's our apology oh
like here's a funny where's our apology
right because here's a photo of olivia
who was literally nine months pregnant
like as if we would literally go out of
our way to get our nine-month pregnancy
we knew we we felt pretty sure we
weren't doing anything wrong but now we
know for certain we weren't doing it
wrong so where's the apology yeah
oh what let me just check the time again
where's the accountability yeah
yeah waiting
more pictures of ben's musk's beard that
was such a crazy time at that point in
time i was extremely grateful for masks
because then i did not have to look at
ben's beard i covered the thing in its
entirety
heaven
okay are you ready to move on from
no i'm honestly not like i'm still
[ __ ] pissed but i will pissy about
what the beard or dinner the dinner
and if you're new here like
don't even don't bother
but going through my camera roll of like
times
like may 2020 covet times
so upsetting
which part
all these pictures in my house yeah
literally like pictures of theo pictures
of me in my mirror like nothing outside
my home oh my god it's so depressing
yeah and for me that whole time like my
screen camera was broken so like all of
my pictures are like blurry it's the
best yeah
yeah i guess okay so the ipad's just
acting a fool today oh my god this ipad
is 45 years old it's time it's time i
got this i this ipad is older than the
toast itself what what what did you buy
it for i bought it when we were doing
the breath because i like didn't want to
always bring my computer so i was like
if i have an ipad it wasn't for stories
initially it was just for like emails
and stuff yeah and now
maybe today's the day she's on her last
leg but she decided
is it really you have to switch to your
phone i'm switching to my phone because
this is unreliable oh my god tech
support i this is unbelievable we need
reliability there's only so much you
could do and the next story i wanted to
get like i actually want to get all the
facts because it's like um
a serious story
you know we're covering serious news
here today we are covering serious news
here today because someone crosses over
into the entertainment world oh i
started the silent patient last night
why because everyone's like the like and
you know i've been
i've been like not reading popular books
because i find like people who talk
about them annoying yeah and then i read
the love hypothesis and i loved it so
much so i'm like maybe i'm the problem
and turns out i am okay i thought the
silent patient was overrated i gave it a
three i think i'm curious to hear what
you think i don't know the twist just
like it didn't do it for me but like
i've had twists that have done for me
that didn't do it for you like the wife
between us yeah the worst book of all
time so
let me know your thoughts also i don't
know if i spoke about this yesterday but
i did um finish book lovers and
literally people were messaging me like
you have to read book lovers it brought
me to tears i'm like it did like you
should not tell people that it's a
terrible book like it was actually so
bad and i've come to the conclusion that
like i'm not an emily henry girl do you
read me trade no and everyone's like you
have to read beetlejuice okay here's the
thing b trade was good you don't have to
read i read people we mean on vacation
and now book lovers and people we meet
on vacation was much better than book
lovers book lovers was real you would
[ __ ] hate it i'm sure i would i hated
people we meet on vacation it was almost
my worst book of 2021 but then i read
wish you were here by jody pickled
i started that
no yeah why no but like a year like a
year ago and i never picked him up in
november oh then we've been picking
these books wish you were here things we
never got over they're all the [ __ ]
same yeah no you wouldn't we were liars
that's what i started okay you wouldn't
if you read wish you were here okay okay
sounds like something i would read
though but maybe it's just like the
vague pronoun and noun title no it's
about coven
oh you told me about that yeah no no no
okay now i have the story okay
law and order organized crime oh my god
a crew member from the show was shot
dead near the show's brooklyn set a law
and order organized crime crew member
has been killed in a shooting near the
tv's set tv show said an nypd
spokesperson told people the 31 year old
male crew member was sitting in his car
on henry street in brooklyn new york
when a gunman opened the car door and
shot the crew member multiple times in
the head and neck the crew member whose
name has not been released was not on
set at the time of the shooting the
spokesperson said the wrap reported that
he was hanging parking restrictions near
tuesday's law order filming location at
around 5 15 a.m when he was approached
by the gunman who has not yet been
identified the victim was taken to
woodhull medical center where he was
pronounced dead
this is such a [ __ ] horrible story
um
and i do have like a few questions like
did somebody show up to this set to kill
this person specifically or like is it
just new york regular crime going on
because it's like on every corner and
this person just got caught in the
crossfire it's unclear the the reports
don't share that either way it's so
terrible
so sad
um
and when i heard the story i just
assumed it was like you know new york
things like happening and it's just it's
terrible it's so scary and
it's just it's really sad and and i
imagine like there were a lot of other
people around who witnessed it and it's
just like horrifying horrifying there
there have been like a lot there's so
much crime in new york and there's also
a lot of like people like bystanders
being shot dead right from like all of
the crimes
friendly fire or whatever it's called
yeah it's not friendly what are they
called friendly firing uh does that mean
like when friendly fires like when
someone on your if you're in a war and
someone on your side like accidentally
kills you oh okay okay that's i
misunderstood then um no it's so [ __ ]
sad and
it just like makes you want to cry yeah
and i feel so like sad for this man and
his family me too have you ever watched
law order organized crime no it's the
stabler spin-off i believe oh is it so
it's new ish
did you see his peloton commercial
bless you
well that was like a weird time sneeze
you know
yeah you feel like the timing of your
sneezes like always means something well
only when it's like people after you
spit some facts and someone sneezes that
means it's true true but i asked you a
question no but sometimes like i'll
sneeze and it just like really helps me
like think of something to say like you
see it was a question right no but so
like it was a meaningless sneeze you
know what i mean
um no what was the question no i haven't
seen his um
commercial new the whole time and it's
like a whole thing there is like a very
um niche group of people who would
literally do anything for elliot stabler
and christopher maloney more
specifically like are you one of those
people like yeah olivia is yeah he's
just had such a unique
journey from like
co-star over like a random show the show
got really big he got really big and
then he left and it like left people
wanting more then he kind of disappeared
for a few years and then he popped back
on the scene like doing random roles and
like being spotted like by random
paparazzi like so looking so buff and
hot and now he's become literally like a
sex symbol yeah it's so weird like the
genesis of christian christopher maloney
yeah but like he's a hard-working man
he's like he waited here like i'm sure
others look at him and they're like oh
christopher like you know he just shows
up naked for a peloton commercial and
it's so easy for him but like he put in
like decades of working on law order
before he popped off in this way yeah
beefcake seeing him like he has a couple
other roles in like random movies where
he like plays dads like seeing him in a
role that's not like a new york city cop
is just not right so i'm glad that they
gave him his own show so he stops doing
other roles because it just feels wrong
it's like seeing you know a teacher
outside of school seeing a dog walk on
its hind legs yeah it reminds me of from
tom sagura's book he has like oh every
other chapter is like stories of when he
ran into celebrities on planes and he
ran into chris noth a while ago and it
was before you know all the christmas
disgrace the disgrace and they were
talking and because he's on law and
order a lot and krishna yeah he's maybe
the old one yeah like one of them
criminal intent and he was kind of
saying how like it doesn't really spark
joy for him and the show that like he
would love to be on that he thinks is
doing amazing things and just it must be
such a pleasure to work on a show like
that this is downton abbey oh my god and
then that conversation inspired tom to
watch downton abbey and he loved it oh
that's a funny little story isn't that
and like it's so sweet that krishna
thinks he could be on downton abbey like
you have to be authentic british that he
should be on downton abbey he was saying
like i would love to be on a show that's
doing things like that
not unlike this cookie cutter it's the
same thing every week yeah but that's
like sorry it's good so no and it's like
a steady paycheck i don't think he was
complaining i think he was just like
speaking as an artist yes of course but
i think the actors who find themselves
on the law and otter type of shows that
go on for years and years like grey's
anatomy things like that consider
themselves some of the luckiest people
in show business because it's such a
steady check yes it's huge platforms
like those shows have so many like such
a big audience you become so famous like
i think marisha hargite is one of the
luckiest people in hollywood yes and if
you were if it were me that would be
enough for me that would be a dream like
die new except i think for some people
who are really interested in the art of
acting
it's stifling well that's just so lame
and losery because if i could be
seriously if i if you were really like
claudia which celebrity in the world
like would you want to be and i really
had to think about like who i want to
spend my lifetime being marishka
hargitay like would be up there she's so
rich she's so famous she is universally
loved and respected and she's married to
peter herman that's really why i would
want to do it i literally watched an
episode of 30 rock this morning i've
been watching it when i get dressed um
with peter herman where he him and list
start dating and they're like what could
go wrong and turns out that they're like
second cousins
um
i think i would melissa mariska hargerty
like would be up there for me and i
think that like iced tea and the actor
who plays like munch like i think they
all would like consider themselves
so blessed yeah
i would want i would be on blue bloods
like you know
that's a steady paycheck you make a lot
of money on those cable sitcoms that
have like big viewers make like a
million dollars in episodes sometimes so
you get so famous you have like
a normal life like i don't think you
like marshall harger take it's paparazzi
so frequently yeah but she's still like
a household name no it's a really good
point yeah like that's the answer to my
question the payoff is just um it's a
little artistically stifling luckily
though like i don't think we're big
artists but see i don't agree that it's
artistically stifling like i think being
a character on lawn arter is filled with
like you know happiness anger sadness
fear like you tap into all of the
emotions but it's the same trope every
episode no we've done it no we're going
to investigate we're going to find a bad
stereotype i think that's not true
i think it's extremely dynamic
i don't disagree
and imagine being a part of a show that
like literally like impacts so many i
could
i could compare any situation in my life
to an episode of svu that i've seen of
course
[Music]
wow
because he's definitely rich and
extremely talented
i wonder what other scores he's written
i wouldn't be surprised if it was han
zimmer honestly
okay well speaking of tv shows paychecks
chris and cavallari and stephen coletti
are revealing their shocking laguna
beach season one salary as well as some
other fun facts from the inception of
laguna beach on their new podcast back
to the beach which is a re-watch show of
laguna beach episodes i think we talked
about that they were doing a show now
the first episode has come out and they
talk about the making of the first
season kristen said i think we were
making 2500 for the first season she
said i don't even he said i don't even
think it was that much i think it was 2
000. lauren and i renegotiated for
season two it was going to be our last
season we're like we're out of here
so they also talked about how the show
began and why they signed on twitter at
17. kristen said i honestly would have
done it for free at that point in high
school to me it was more of a
competition everybody wanted it and i
was like i'm gonna get this show i'm
super competitive that has not changed
so when they told us they were going to
pay us i was like oh my god great mtv
producers came to the laguna beach high
school to cast the show giving
interested students 20 page packets to
fill out steven knew he wanted to work
in the entertainment industry and wanted
to host so he thought he should get to
know the mtv producers while he doesn't
remember anything about the questions
kristin recalled more she said it was
like list your five best friends and
what you hate about them she says she
remembers one of the questions was who
do you think is going to be prom queen
she said i don't know i just hope it's
not lauren conrad l-o-l-l she said the
questions were sending us how to divulge
all of this information obviously they
were trying to get to the bottom of
things which they did
so that's pretty interesting
yeah i'm like struggling because i have
like a personal vendetta against kristen
cavallari um i don't know if she knows
about it but i do and i'm like trying
like not to you know like blow it up on
social media but i'm upset
do you
one sounds like you want to talk about
it do you know what my personal people
is when i think it could be easily
squashed and i think like generally
speaking she's a great gal
well you know my i don't really know her
i don't
personally know her but i've had one you
know negative interaction and i'm really
honestly like it's like it's bothering
me
i don't know what you should do about it
okay i don't know just like i can't give
an honest opinion on the story because
i'm like clouded by my my i'm mad like
i'm a can't separate like the personal
from like the job of like just talking
you should be upset too like she did
like us
yeah our business yeah but could you
imagine being like in her situation and
how potentially like how she doesn't
know that she did that
maybe some of the person who was
supposed to tell her what to do well
then maybe if i blow up her spot she
literally owes us she owes us okay you
seem like you want to share okay so
here's what happened
literally like over the summer you know
for spring last summer because last
summer oh right
first brits be like a pr company and
they're always bringing us like cool
opportunities like do you want to
sponsor this event you know there'll be
cool influence or celebrities there um
and we sponsored uh a christian cavalry
event i think it was uncommon james her
jewelry company it was something chris
and cavalier related and we donated all
the product it was totally free and in
exchange they owed us like a couple
things on social one including like
something from kristin literally she
never posted like we followed up a
thousand times she never posted oh you
call it up a thousand times directly or
two people sure people like for some
reason like it bothered me like i was
like no actually i'm not letting this go
and i was like let's follow up let's
follow up never never
so
we donated we're like a startup company
we donated all this product for your
event we like made it premium and you're
out here like
not returning the deliverables i don't i
don't approve of that i don't know i'm a
businesswoman not delivering on
deliverables i don't approve of that
either so honestly i can't give an
honest opinion on what i think about
this podcast because i'm clouded by my
anger and my resentment and she could
make it right she could post you know a
candle spritz today tag spritz like
that's all it really it wasn't that hard
thing was like maybe a couple instagram
stories and then like they were like
well kristen hasn't tried the product so
she doesn't like to post like what she
doesn't i'm like well we literally gave
her 400 cans like what was she doing
for free
so i just don't appreciate people who
don't respect businesses you know yeah
like i try to always do the right thing
yeah and i've just honestly been wanting
to bring that up for a while so i'm glad
i can feel that i'm glad that you i'm
glad you got that off your chest and i
said i was like okay you know what
nevermind i'm gonna make myself look bad
if i keep talking okay but i think
that's fair like that that's clouding
your judgment on this story yeah and
honestly tmlc anyways
back then yeah yes but but now it's like
she gives us nothing she gives us
nothing but that like she's
intentionally giving us very little and
kristen like gives us so much as a
celebrity she did reality tv she's an
influencer
a business owner podcaster
podcaster now yeah no i agree like back
in the day was elsie or die like there
was no way i would ever even begin to
understand cake have but now and i
totally respect the root that lauren has
taken and honestly
it must be nice to like not need to do
all of these things because like
her lineup kmart all that [ __ ] is like
super successful like she's at peace and
i love that for her um but now it's like
everyone keeps talking about laguna
beach the hills reliving it and we don't
ever hear from her so it's like she's
kind of been cast now by like spencer
and heidi and everyone has the villain
yeah and i think that happens a lot
where it's like things that you look
back on it's like the person that you
thought was the victim was actually the
villain i don't think that's the
situation but we're so used to that
happening that it's like oh the person
who we liked
immediately
at that time maybe they were the villain
it reminds me so unfortunately by the
way i feel like i know what you're gonna
say terry said melissa i was gonna say
jill and bethany
oh but we no like it reminds me of trees
and melissa cause we all love theresa so
much that when melissa came on the show
we all just like hated her for nothing
and yeah they treated her so poorly and
like
now when you look back on it's like
she did nothing she did nothing wrong
like why were we so mean to this girl so
i think that happens a lot where we look
back on something and it's like oh we
were actually like mistreating someone
who's totally fine
like the way everyone used to talk about
her and like her mental health and now
we're like we can't believe we used to
do that oh yes yes yes but i'm really
just thinking i'm like on reality like
the person that you thought was the
champion maybe was actually the mean
person so i feel that way about jill and
bethany because back in the day like i
was hardcore team jill but i think
mostly people sided with bethany and
when i rewatched it like i was even more
like
digging my feet in on being team jail
like people just cast jail as like this
evil person who couldn't be happy for
bethany like that's really not what it
was yeah so i i agree with you i think
like the perception over time really
chan over time really changes for people
and so also just like a part of growing
up yes exactly so i even though i do
think like elsie was a nice girl i think
we're
we just like are
realizing that shows put people into
these roles and that i'm sure kristen
cavallari was just like playing a role
of course and i think what we've learned
from people who are on the hills on
laguna beach who like speak out about it
it's like it was all like acting
i feel like this first season was not
though laguna beach yeah yes i think
when we got to the hills it was became
so much bigger than they imagined it was
pure acting right but no laguna beach
season one was raw them getting paid
2000 or 2500 is so crazy but it does
really track the first housewives of new
york they got paid like seven thousand
dollars for the whole season so like
it's crazy how you started literally
this was one of the biggest reality
shows of all time they started getting
paid two thousand dollars a season and
now like some housewives are getting
paid a million dollars a season but no
one season one episode one no but still
season one episode one i think you make
like minimum on bravo at least like ten
thousand dollars per episode yes and the
fact that they used to pay people per
season is so crazy right but they were
17 and this was before inflation so
that's true maybe that's like 10 000 per
episode now right you have to counter in
inflation you really do you do you
really do are you ready for our fifth
and final story yeah linda evangelista
has um is this the girl you used to
never get out of bed before for ten
thousand dollars yes and then she shared
that she was like botched by cool school
yeah and now she has settled her 50
million dollar coolscope queen cool
sculpting lawsuit over her quote botched
result so linda evangelista has settled
a lawsuit over a botched cosmetic
procedure that she claims left her quote
deformed the supermodel announced on
instagram tuesday that the saga was over
after
suing coolsculpting's parent company
zeltiq aesthetics for 50 million dollars
in damages she said i'm pleased to have
settled the case i look forward to the
next chapter of my life with friends and
family and i'm happy to put this matter
behind me i'm truly grateful for the
support i have received from those who
have reached out the terms of the
settlement are not immediately clear but
you could probably use your imagination
yeah
okay love like a medical malpractice
moment where someone gets a lot of money
because that's just like
justice that's justice except like
that she had to endure all that
obviously yeah but and i'm sure if you
asked her like would you rather have say
it's 25 million or
not have had that experience is it
justice or i don't know what people or
is it just something 25 million is a lot
i think some people might say like i
would have endured it for the 25 million
like things like this i really do make
situations like traumatizing situations
a lot better a lot better but do they
make it wow
i don't know it depends on what the
situation is and how much money it is
yeah and what they value yeah
yeah so
closing the chapter on that book
honestly that story really stuck with me
because there were many times in my life
when i definitely thought like maybe i
should do coolsculpting and then in the
back of my mind i was like that story
you know yeah i didn't remember if it
was like chrissy turlington or like
which model was but i knew there was
like a crazy
possibility of it going wrong and that's
why i never did it because i would love
to do it on my fupa like hypothetically
in theory it sounds amazing you know
back in the day i would have like i
actually thought i'd be a great
candidate for just like my little tummy
and then but i had heard that it's not
effective so i was like oh okay so i
won't do it
now i'm glad that yeah so she's
educating and she's working it in and
she's sharing and opening up and that's
very brave and i'm happy for her because
that that's gotta help
yeah but money isn't everything
no
but it is neither are looks no but they
are no meaning but there's something but
they're not everything it's true but not
one thing is everything i think that's
the point um
deeply moved that's so true family is
everything
no
timing is everything timing is
everything i mean speaking of timing
it's time for dear toasters
our advice segment toast is everything
that's so true brass and stress or
everything but how can all of these
things be everything it's all of them
together because not one thing is
everything
though we keep saying that they are and
it's time for your toasters our advice
segment everything oh my god our advice
segment every wednesday you can write in
deer toasters gmail.com we will always
keep your [ __ ] anonymous and you can
write in about anything from family
friends relationships work
whatever ready
whatever and write in about whatever
sauce yes that's our kind of our
specialty yeah and it's snitch's
specialty i know she also does advice
and it's counselor snitch gmail.com she
does counseling on her show um why
doesn't everyone just spam her with
subject line whatever sauce whatever
songs i'm having really hard trouble
trying to decide like what to get my
muscles with do you have any
recommendations for a good sauce
try whatever sauce
all right and by the way like we i by
the way i loved your toasters but i find
it like extremely fatiguing
um like emotionally trained training
yeah so if we just keep stalling that's
fine i don't feel like we will be like
successful in life until there is
a sauce brand on shelves with margo's
face on it that's called whatever sauce
i think we should do it what kind of
sauce like margaret loves hot sauce we
have to make our own brand of hot sauce
yes but it also should be a
collaboration with ben the king of
sauces that's called whatever sauce and
it's just like our family sauces i kind
of love that idea by the way love talk
to ben about it we need to write it down
with like big ideas
okay toast tunes yes yes and whatever
sauce if anybody works in like the food
space like help us like big ideas
whatever sauce toast tunes
toast tunes i think that's it yeah i
have some other like personal ideas let
me just write them down so that when it
happens
yeah okay cool go to space
be the first podcasters in space
if we got that opportunity like one of
those companies then we would be the
biggest podcast in space yeah on
interplanetary podcast since we're not
the biggest podcaster in any state we
might as well go to a different planet
you try our like if we had that
opportunity it was like first
i mean you have a kid now so like it's a
little different my answer is no i have
no interest in going to space honestly
but if they literally like if it was
elon like someone you trusted
no no it was spacex like we're putting
together another moronic recreational
flight but we want you to be the first
two podcasters in space okay then you do
a lot then that would mean that elon
would know my name because like he would
look at like you know that he'd have to
prove it it's very possible elon doesn't
know your name like did you read my book
that's true elon told me he loved my
blog when i met him at a party so also
elon is a very like up on everything
that's just about him yeah like you saw
those pictures of him on the boat and
then he tweeted like free the nipple
he's very in tune with with the culture
of surrounding elon so like it's
possible that also there's toaster that
work at spacex there are
it's possible that someone has been like
these girls are big fans of yours i
don't think the possibility of us being
asked to like go to space as the first
podcasters is that crazy honestly no
because we are those like crazy podcasts
and we're like
actually every podcaster is crazy it's
criteria to be in this business yeah but
like whether people refuse to admit
they're not like we're a huge podcast
like yeah i would say of like the top
we're in like the top 20 biggest
podcasts in like in america
did you say that yes and you can't go by
the charts because the charts are
influenced by like new podcasts so like
a lot of what's top in the charts like
they're taught like when we launched our
show we were number one right now i'm
talking about like audience size
audience size over time consistently yes
i think so so i just think like the
possibility that we would be asked to go
to space like isn't that crazy
no it's not delusional like no no no and
i would only go if it were spacex spacex
and like i had some assurance that like
elon signed off on this but i'm like
scared i'm scared obviously i would
literally shave my pants i would not be
able the podcast would just be like a
fart soundtrack because i'd be like
farting the whole time i'd be so nervous
oh my i would be quaking that would be
the audio we would literally like three
two one we blast off and you and i would
just be like ross and stress
just screaming our heads up no like
literally i would have to be
institutionalized afterwards i'd be so
scared i don't even want roller coasters
but we would go viral no of course and
like finally maybe we'd become the
biggest podcast in a certain state or in
a certain galaxy
um so yeah we're open to it call us so
let me put in big ideas podcasting from
space so that one i could give or take
yeah like i don't have to do it like it
would be cool podcasting from spacex i'm
not going on blue origin sorry jeff no
yeah like i want i'll go with like nasa
like someone legit like in the space
blue rj what is it like four years old
maybe less i want to go with like
someone who's been in this space for a
while
elon okay do your toasters any other big
ideas you just want to put out there no
that's it oh obviously jackson east of
fashion line oh right right right max
collab
oh my
god you know what we would call the
collab
cj max
claudia jackie he's like that's actually
a good idea write it down write it down
we need to like make some of this like
[ __ ] come to fruition i know but now
it's this maybe we're manifesting i also
really at one point like want to do home
shopping
yeah we could do that with our cj max
line yeah or with spritz
yeah but we do home shopping on sports
every day here yeah that's true but i
just i know like when i marco was on qvc
a lot for her job and like i just
sometimes like to watch qvc and i watch
it and i know i can be so good and so
funny and like really speak to the women
of america like i know that i could for
sure but i just want you to know like
every day that we do our ads like that's
kind of what we're doing no but i want
to be like home shopping is on in like
100 million homes yeah but also that's
why we need like our own clothes that we
can speak to yeah
okay ready for deardressers
yeah hi jackson claude love you both so
much and i've been listening since the
morning breath i'm so proud of where you
two have come from and jackie i'm so
happy for you and your big move
even though youtube will never be the
same
10 years ago i casually saw a guy named
maverick over the summer it really
wasn't anything but i'm a relationship
type of girl and i was pretty infatuated
with him even though he wasn't looking
for a relationship at all
since then i've met the love of my life
and i'm happily married with two kids
but at least once a month i dream about
maverick i can't understand why because
first it's been 10 years second i am
married to the most amazing person
literally the best husband i could ask
for and third maverick treated me pretty
awfully he often said weird things
showed me zero respect and the sex
wasn't even good so she has dreams like
at night about yeah that said why do i
keep dreaming about maverick he did come
into my life at a pivotal time he
basically gave me the courage to get out
of my first marriage to a person who was
likely a pedophile oh my god but like i
said he wasn't a good guy so why is my
subconscious still hung up on him love
you both a toaster is haunted by your
dreams i feel like this is like so
normal i think it's so normal too and
i'm sure like
i don't know a lot about dreams but it's
never just like
one is one and maverick is maverick it's
like he's a your subconscious
manifestation of something or other and
it sounds like he played like an
important part in your life like he's
kind of like was this like transitional
person for you like he was able to show
you like you don't have to be with this
man and then you ended up like having
this amazing life with your husband so i
don't think it says anything bad about
your marriage or your relationship like
he represents the past or represents a
different version of you i don't think
it says anything about especially if you
can like sit here and say like no he's
nothing compared to the man that i'm
with and i think also your mind might be
playing tricks on you cause it's like
stop dreaming about maverick okay i'm
gonna dream about maverick yeah like and
also i just think like in your life
people you get fixated on like random
people and it means nothing but you do
feel weird like thinking about them you
know yeah but i think the fact that you
think about them is like kind of normal
i think it's totally fine
what like okay you get married you could
never dream about anyone else ever again
do you know many people we've met in our
lives yeah i don't think this is crazy
at all and i think like you shouldn't be
like worried about it and i really
oscillate between like dreams being
meaningless to like they are
the most intimate picture of yourself
that you can share and it's like i just
don't see how that's i've heard that
that's true but i just don't see it i
think it's both like
some are i think some dreams are
meaningless and some of them like are a
real testament of like what's going on
in your subconscious
and i think sometimes like you can
literally like
connect with like other worlds in your
dreams i really believe that i also
think that a lot of people don't know
what's going on in their subconscious so
the dream might feel
like so random but it's like actually
you just aren't in touch
with maybe that's what's going on with
me i also think that there are people
who like don't really dream or if they
do they never remember them and like
that makes me sad because like my dreams
are like some of my favorite parts of my
day i'm like let's go to bed and go to a
fantasy world you know it could go
either way for me it's a
i'm not crazy about dreams oh i kind of
like love dreams because either i have a
terrible dream which is just
there's nothing wrong with a setting or
i have an incred dream and it's like
[ __ ] i just woke up to this life i'll
literally never forget like the most
vivid dream i had in high school where
like zac efron like wanted to marry me
and then you woke up and you weren't mrs
ephron jackie when i tell you how
depressed i was and it was like real
[ __ ] depression because the dream had
felt so real it was like this come down
i can't even explain how real it was
that's what i'm saying that was hard so
good or bad
it's bad right it's bad right that's
true okay
um next up dear claudia and jackie i'm
in desperate need of advice okay my
husband and i just caught wind that one
of our close friends maverick attempted
to cheat on his long-term girlfriend
about a year ago without ricky dirty dog
with another one of our friends tina
tina didn't go into detail but it was
clear that maverick crossed a line and
left her feeling incredibly
uncomfortable uncomfortable enough to
reevaluate a 10-year friendship and they
have not spoken since i fully trust that
tina is telling the truth now the real
predicament is that maverick is planning
on proposing to his girlfriend within
the year my husband and i are sure that
she has no idea about what he did or
does and maverick had a tendency to be a
fuckboy in college but we all thought
that he grew out of that phase what
should i do do we tell maverick's
girlfriend do we tell maverick that we
know what happened with him and tina and
force him to tell his girlfriend do we
stay out of it for context maverick and
his girlfriend live together and have
been together for three years maverick
also
married my husband and me so we're very
close with them both please help thanks
i'm just like always a fan of staying
out of people's business yeah it's also
like the easier thing to do and i and i
do think it's like what's right
i don't know i don't know but it's not i
feel like every time we get this
question like every other different
formats and i feel like every other week
we say the opposite of the week before
the reason why i think the situation
like might be worth getting into because
it sounds like it's not like he's just
cheating but he's being like a cheater
no like she said like
the situation with tina left her feeling
incredibly uncomfortable like he's like
being predatory yeah not like abusive
because that's like an extreme word like
niparius nefarious and it's not like
consensual and it's not like he got
swept up with someone who was like you
know putting loose on him as well it's
like he's being a creep yeah and i think
that like
that's even more extreme than
like marrying someone who's a cheater
you're marrying someone who's a cheater
but who also takes advantage of women
like i actually do feel like you have
some sort of like
yeah i would want to know and you know
what in this situation it and i say this
every week a letter
no i think a letter i think you should
have tina tell her not you stay out of
it yeah cause her and maverick aren't
even friends anymore so like yeah tell
tina like go to her woman to woman yeah
but see like some women don't want to
[ __ ] hear it
yeah but at least tina and her aren't
super close so like if she just wants to
put her head in the sand and like not
talk to tina anymore like that's fine at
least it's not going to affect your
friendship yeah
throw the ball to tina
yeah it's in tina's court now
tina and maverick tina
tina tina tina
all right third and final hello jack's
club tina bruno and theo that's a pretty
name this is complex so stick with that
okay wait they wanted the stress
brother's time for this one to start off
my therapist and my boss are sisters i
know it's a little inappropriate already
but that is not the point
this past thursday i was at a bar with
my roommate a place where we typically
see people we know but this had been a
quiet one until maverick and his friend
walked in you guys are wild
maverick is the first cousin of my boss
anyway it's hard to like keep
disassociating that from one maverick to
the next okay
maverick is creeping on tina maverick is
the first cousin of my boss and my
therapist you needed to move to a bigger
city
and her boss recently got married
i also happen to know wait no this is
very confusing maverick is the first
cousin of my boss and therapist and
maverick recently got married
i also have the maverick i also happen
to know that maverick's wife i happen to
know maverick's wife because we go to
the same gym and we see each other
weekly it's a very small town
literally at the bar one thing leads to
another and we all went back to my place
to hang out we stayed up playing games
and drinking until my roommate went to
bed and maverick said we should take the
party to his house and we did
once again before i know it one thing
was leading to another and i was
wrecking a home in the guest bedroom the
following morning after he dropped me
off at home i had a therapy session
where i was stuck between a rock and a
hard place on whether to tell my
therapist or not i ultimately did not
but what do i do do i tell my therapist
do i tell my boss and risk causing so
much drama and losing this amazing
relationship with them both how do i
face the wife when i see her at the gym
weekly okay so this is confusing
basically she [ __ ] her bosses and her
therapist cousin who's married and she
knows the wife and sees her at the gym
yeah and so like she her can she tell
her therapist yeah hipaa
hipaa but like
i don't know do you really need to talk
about this in therapy i just feel like
this is something we should move on
that's like the problem but it's like if
you're not talking about the fact that
you cheated and like we're an adult or
in therapy where are you going okay but
like here's the thing and this is like i
love therapy but like for me and i feel
like you and i just have this
conversation like
sometimes like you do want to forget
about things like uh sleeping with a
married man is one of those things like
we just sweep under the rug and like
want to forget about but can therapy
like you have to talk about it and it's
like becomes a whole thing it just
depends if something's like a one-off or
it's like part of your personality
[ __ ] married men yeah yeah we need to
explore it sounds like this was like a
first time situation for this girl but
will it be the last you definitely want
to talk about in there because it just
over complicates things and like maybe
you start seeing a therapist
yeah
then it makes it awkward though like if
you're friends with a therapist and i
just want to know how you got yourself
this is like
it reminds me of like shit's creepy
jackie i was gonna say every tyler movie
where tyler perry plays all the
characters like how do you know everyone
and how is everyone related yeah no it's
like a sitcom yeah like the owner of the
mayor is also the handyman yeah yes
exactly just confusing to me and then
like you have to go and tell the
therapist and she then her plot plotline
is like what does she do with this
information does she violate hipaa or
not if you don't really feel like you
need to talk about it in therapy just
like drop it or you could be like i
slept with a married man you don't have
to say it was your cousin girl
i know but then it's just like how many
married men are there in this town right
there might only be one married couple
in this whole town so by process of
elimination
i just think like
if you don't even want to talk about it
in therapy don't tell your boss for sure
because like then that crosses personal
like work boundaries and it happens to
be your cousin i just feel like you
should take this to the grave honestly
like no one needs to know and just
just move on
yeah but what would bryce do
bryce would do the right thing
yeah which is
move
get a new job new therapist
yeah that's what bryce would do
wwbd
what would rice do
that was your toasters if you ever want
to write it it's dear toasters gmail.com
thank you so much for writing and being
open with us thank you so much for
listening to the toaster reminder this
was our last show of the week we're back
um on monday we have episodes every day
next week but they are audio only so
make sure you're subscribed to wherever
you get podcasts spotify itunes um
tickets available to my tour at
girlandjob.comtour
over at patreon.com the morning toast
and that's our show slash the morning
toast thank you so much for listening to
the morning show the monday morning show
where we deliver stories that you need
to know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcasting podcasts
can be found spotify institute public
video i already guest box all the places
swimming listen to the podcast find out
this morning chelsea five star review
about our beautiful stunning and smart
we are hope you guys have an incredible
day in creole rest of the week have a
great weekend and we'll see you guys
we'll hear you guys on monday bye
everyone
bye tina bye
you